le vaginisme c'est une contraction à
volontaire des muscles du périnée on a
au niveau du petit bassin du bas-ventre
si vous voulez donc on appelle ça
vaginisme du coup parce que ces muscles
ils entourent notamment le vagin et son
ouverture du coup quand il se contracte
ils empêchent la pénétration ou en tout
cas il la rendent difficile et
douloureuse si on parle de relation
sexuelles on sait que c'est pas non plus
un problème de libido de désir
d'excitation ou de lubrification
naturelle on connaît pas tout si bien
que ça parce que c'est rare c'est sans
doute plutôt parce que les questions de
santé sexuelle féminine sont moins bien
étudiés que les autres il peut aussi
être présent soit tout le temps soit
seulement dans certains cas ok mais à
quoi c'est dû on la majorité des cas
c'est psychologique ça peut être causé
par des douleurs ou une mauvaise
expérience liée au première pénétration
pas forcément dans un cas de sexuel
d'ailleurs ça peut être lié à des
traumatismes parfois c'est lié à
l'éducation ou aux croyances le sexe
c'est mal le sexe c'est sale etc donc tu
vois c'est l'inconscient qui s'imagine
que le vagin est trop petit pour être
pénétré il y a plein plein de causes
différentes et il peut même y avoir
plusieurs causes c'est la même personne